un hall de gare transformée en dortoir
le seul endroit où ces familles
ukrainienne épuisé peuvent se reposer
quelques heures tous ont passé la
frontière cette nuit mais n'ont pour
l'instant aucun autre point de chute ce
sont des militaires polonais qui leur
propose le petit déjeuner
il y a beaucoup de gens à la frontière
et ça devient impossible impossible si
on n'avait pas eu beaucoup de chance on
ne serait pas encore arrivé ici
je suis grand mère et j'ai fui avec mes
petits enfants on est effrayé pour nos
enfants la situation fait peur
ce père de famille cherche maintenant à
moyen de rejoindre londres où vivent
certains de ses proches je dois me
battre mais la priorité c'est de mettre
mais les enfants en sécurité et après
peut-être je retournerai me battre dans
mon pays plusieurs trains en provenance
d'ukraine sont attendues cet après midi
la solidarité s'organise neuf centres
d'accueil sont en train d'être mise en
place côté polonais avec des volontaires
comme ici près du poste frontière pour
accueillir ceux qui arrivent papier
on a trouvé un super chauffeur il est
venu de poznan pour y emmener des gens
gratuitement
selon l'onu déjà cent mille personnes
ont fui leurs foyers en ukraine cette
famille s'est décidé à partir en urgence
après avoir entendu les premières
explosions et hier ils n'ont pris avec
eux que quelques bagages
on vient de le vivre on a pris nos
affaires appeler un taxi mais on a dû
marcher longtemps pour terminer le
trajet
j'ai 70 ans
et comment ça s'est passé on a pu
franchir la frontière à 5 heures du
matin il y avait énormément de gens mais
grâce à dieu on a réussi
dans les voitures qui arrivent il n'y a
ce matin que des femmes depuis cette
nuit les hommes âgés de 18 à 60 ans
d'interdiction de quitter l'ukraine en
vertu de la loi martiale imposée dans le
pays
on a attendu plus de dix heures pour
passer dix heures avec des enfants qui
pleurent sens tueur sans eau
mais maintenant ça va
d'après les autorités polonaises tous
les ukrainiens qui se présentent à ce
poste frontière peuvent passer rentrer
en europe mais vous le voyez il n'y a
ici qu'une seule voie d'ouverte dans ce
sens les contrôles menés par les
douaniers sont très longs les arrivées
en voiture non doc lieu pour l'instant
qu'au compte gouttes